now you see the outfit that uh Uma
Thurman wears in it is is in itself a
cinematic reference fans or admirers of
the legendary Bruce Lee well remember
that his unfinished Masterpiece the
movie he was working on when he died
under tragic some still believe in
mysterious circumstances he wears outfit
in Game of Death uh which is there you
go right there
now you're referencing that in the movie
when it comes to martial arts and movies
that's actually one of the most iconic
images of the entire genre what a great
suit yeah now for years I've loved that
suit as well and a year and a half ago
my wife had one of those suits made for
me are you serious yeah no I am the only
problem with that suit is and see mine's
the real one because Uma you cheat in
the movie Uma you've made it into a top
and trousers yes exactly yeah well I
made a little I made it a little bit
more flattering to a woman I understand
and also a bit easier to use for example
when I got the toilet look what we have
to do here
there you go I have to take it wiped out
yeah you know we had a movie to make I
didn't have time for her to go through a
production every time she went to the
can